here is a independent Pennsylvanian
voter talking about how he's going to
change his position now that he's seen
the debate
so I was definitely I'm an independent
by the way I was definitely leaning
towards fetterman and I think I have
totally changed to the Oz side why I
felt that um fetterman I felt that
fetterman just looked like he didn't
have command of the facts I do think his
condition unfortunately is going to
affect his ability to do the job I
thought Oz uh was pretty clear on the
issues and I thought he presented
himself well and definitely threw out
some plans where I didn't see any plans
coming out of fetterman okay I know
these things are anecdotal but it's
interesting that you know that there
still are undecided people in the
country is sort of interesting because
the parties are so different right this
isn't like okay am I voting for George
H.W bush or Bill Clinton right where
it's like they both kind of like America
one wants a little bit more taxes you
know but the stuff is kind of the same
to some degree right uh this is like
really really different stuff this is
all of the woke stuff and the open
borders and the race stuff and the crime
and the drugs and the defunding of the
police versus like basic Law and Order
and America's decent and we believe in
the Constitution so I find it
interesting that there are these
undecided type people but this guy
seemed like a decent enough guy and I
think he rep he obviously represents
some sliver of people that are still
undecided maybe it's just that they
don't pay that much attention to
politics except when the elections roll
around and that's that's actually just
fine for a certain segment of the
society uh so it's interesting that he
saw this thing and then it finally hit
him you know he said he was leaning
fetterman so it's hard to understand
like what his political leanings are
maybe that means he's more generally
thought of as a Democrat but after
watching that thing basically he said
fetterman can't communicate his ideas
something ain't quite right and now I'm
going on I I think a lot of people for
whatever sliver of people are still
undecided in Pennsylvania they I cannot
imagine I genuinely cannot but I will if
we can find video of it I will gladly
play it tomorrow if you find me video of
anyone I mean literally anyone please
send it to us of somebody that was like
I watched that debate last night and I
thought John fetterman was excellent I
was on the fence I thought maybe I was
going to vote for Oz and now I'm voting
for John Federman it's I I cannot I
literally cannot imagine that that such
a person could exist